con casi 3.700 muertos durante la última
jornada india registró su día más mortal
desde el inicio de la pandemia las
morgues y los crematorios han estado
luchando por mantenerse al día con el
número de fallecidos durante casi dos
semanas los hospitales se han visto
desbordados por la afluencia de
pacientes lo que ha provocado una
escasez de camas y oxígeno
la ayuda médica ya ha empezado a llegar
para hacer frente a la situación
estamos trayendo 120 ventiladores que
serán distribuidos a los hospitales por
la cruz roja'
pero es exactamente lo que se necesita
esa es la primera gran entrega que
estamos trayendo último
los suministros de uzbekistán bélgica
francia y alemania- se descargaron este
domingo como parte de un esfuerzo
internacional masivo para ayudar a india
a combatir su peor momento de la
pandemia en respuesta a la emergencia el
gobierno ha ampliado la elegibilidad
para la vacuna a todos los adultos
mayores de 18 años pero varios estados
informaron que no tenían suficientes
antídotos a pesar de ser el mayor
productor de vacunas del mundo india
sufre una escasez interna y ha
suspendido temporalmente las
exportaciones del fármaco de astrazéneca
para satisfacer la demanda del país
recibió una dosis cuando fui por la
segunda dijeron que no estaba disponible
así que no la he recibido dijeron que
las vacunas para las personas mayores de
18 años comenzarían hoy pero volvieron a
hacerlo sería bueno que todos la
recibieran
hasta ahora el primer ministro se ha
resistido a imponer otro confinamiento
nacional después de que el último
provocó que la producción de india
cayera en un récord de 24% pero la
comunidad médica dice que es la única
forma de romper la cadena de transmisión
varios estados han seguido adelante con
sus propios cierres para tratar de
detener la propagación del virus